all right and today is Monday and we're
doing the daily show tracks sidetrack we
went out today we bought some stuff I
hadn't been out in how long have I not
been outside I mean I've been outside
and that I go out walking on the trail
but I haven't like been anywhere like in
the car yeah I was afraid like that the
car wouldn't start because it's just
been sitting there the driveway yeah it
really wasn't much going on it's pretty
slow yeah we just
I mean honestly we just had to go to the
liquor store obviously because you know
we go through here a lot in this house
yeah and then we had to go you know we
went to Walgreens right and it's like
there wasn't a hell of a lot of people
in there and they stopped pretty much
everything back up except the whole
paper aisle is still empty I ended up
spending 70 [ __ ] $3.00 yeah basket
yeah well it's because we didn't want to
go to like a whole bunch of different
place like I don't want have to go to
the grocery store and all these others
so we had to buy like [ __ ] cat treats
and makeup and [ __ ] what the hell
else do we get in there I got like a
hold [ __ ] ton of soup because they had
all their soup was on sale man even like
the Progresso stuff yeah oh um you guys
need to go watch a movie we saw it last
night it's [ __ ] fantastic of a very
very now it's gonna be a mixed bag some
people don't like it but this is a
[ __ ] trip movie some people might
think what man does you know this is
nonsense no it makes a lot of sense
if you think about the meaning of it was
pretty [ __ ] honest I mean sense just
watch that in the first five minutes it
sets it up and just you know some it's a
science fiction horror movie yeah we did
we did like um we already recorded like
a like a longer review for the matinee
show we're Horning up on Saturday or
Sunday yeah it's like it's hard not to
spoil this and I said this on the thing
it's like it's so so hard to talk about
it's like I wish I could because it's
like there's so much like there's so
much going on in this [ __ ] my xbox has
it for $6.99 and either an SD or HD just
watch the [ __ ] in HD you know the same
price and it's worth the $6.99 I loved
this one of the best movies of the year
I love that it has
same cast as in the martial arts would
artists self-defense art of self-defense
Jesse Eisenberg and Imogen Poots yeah
they do a great job so you're a-peein
flick yeah european fun but it's not
boring like a european flee without its
and these people go watch the trailer
just look at the trailer yeah the
trailer a while back in the water [ __ ]
and I was like ooh that looks good and
it's weird but we have a good weird yeah
very very weird and it's very dark and
it makes a lot of sense when you pay
attention to what the movie is trying to
tell you
yeah and it's a great I woke up this
morning thinking about it see and it's
like he hardly ever does that I was
[ __ ] riveted to it he wasn't like I
don't think you picked up your tablet a
single dime like the whole movie and
that never happened no these people get
into this damn survival situation where
they're [ __ ] trying to combat the
unknown and they don't know what it is
they're dealing with yeah until it's too
late it was freaky [ __ ] yeah I I really
really like that and I wouldn't mind
seeing it again actually owning it but
yeah it's definitely worth watching I
think probably tonight I might watch
because we've spent so much for like
renting movies but I think tonight I'll
probably watch the occupant on Netflix
because that's like a new 2020 film I
believe it's Spanish and it looked kind
of intriguing from the trailer looks
like a creepy thriller which and I like
those so that might be the next thing
that we do for the matinee show I think
underwater is coming out to four it's
out its out already
yeah and get it on blu-ray yeah I bet I
plot what plug that movie many times it
bombed bomb bigger than [ __ ] man that
was a [ __ ] awesome movie I like I
really liked it - we saw it twice I did
in the theater it was just like
something right out of damn alien
yeah well the Prometheus and I think
maybe that's why because people like
it's just like alien yeah alien but
underwater alien but underwater which it
was but it's like that's okay yeah I
mean look the thing is everything's been
done yeah pretty much I I haven't seen
anything like that was like blew my mind
with originality or anything I mean you
can do like variations on [ __ ] I think
people don't like that actress or
something I liked her in this movie
Stuart um you know she's
still gets bagged even though she's been
in a million other things since Twilight
but she gets back them because of that
matter of fact I just watched on [ __ ]
and I think I mentioned this on one of
the other side tracks I just watched
that movie Lizzie on shudder about
Lizzie Borden and Kristen Stewart was in
that play in the the main Bridget
Sullivan so if you guys don't have thing
to do see poveri and we're gonna talk
about that that's gonna be coming up on
the mat nation asia vivarium see that
one and if you haven't seen underwater
see it yeah that's available to rent
also I saw it it came up yesterday or
the day before like on the Xbox rental
thing so you know we probably we've seen
it a couple times already because like I
said we were it's like but yeah I
mentioned it to a friend of mine he's
like what's that [ __ ] is it like a
five and not Leviathan was the one where
they were underneath the dam well there
was several Leviathan and there was one
called the abyss yes yes can't look like
the the abyss huh and I was like no he
was but it's underwater this is so if it
since jaws was underwater too so if it's
in outer space if it's an outer space
it's always Flash Gordon yeah there's
only so many settings you know it's
either on earth or at in space yeah you
know I'm Tom eyes that stupid dude this
stupid dude well that does not no no
okay
oh okay you know exactly I'm talking
about wait that little dude is always
sucking talking [ __ ] yeah yeah I don't
get that at all like I said I'm I'm all
for originality in films and for doing
like some experimental [ __ ] but
sometimes you just want to see something
that's you know like you know that
somebody takes like a concept like for
example zombies yeah if I never see
another zombie movie it'll be too soon
however train to Busan right you can
still do good [ __ ] with it and the
kingdom yeah exactly
you can still do good [ __ ] with the TRO
chair though the trailer for [ __ ]
train to Busan
- looks [ __ ] great yeah what's they
called Peninsula condense those what's
called and it seemed like kind of like a
post-apocalyptic um shout looks like
it's in a post-apocalyptic soul it looks
like a skate from New York
yeah those zombies that's gonna be
people with modified [ __ ] hot rods
and [ __ ] gladiator games and you know
the Koreans went feral look cool well I
feel like that's gonna happen in any
kind of zombie apocalypse yeah sure a
little while just like Walking Dead and
stuff right which reminds me I have
missed the last season of The Walking
Dead cuz I forgot that it came back on I
forgot that it existed well and then cuz
I had watched we watched like the last
seatt what was the last season season 8
and then I guess he's a nice guy and
then we used to see it anymore
that's true remember that Rick left and
then that was the last episode and then
we didn't see the season after yeah so I
didn't I don't think I saw any is he's a
nine or season 10 or whatever the hell
season is on we're several seasons to
find I think now I think we're just one
behind oh the one that just aired and
fear The Walking Dead jerked me off for
so long without [ __ ] to pay off I was
just like [ __ ] it that's like I really
had hope for that and it's like it just
it's it's starting out good and then it
got kind of shitty and then it got
really good but it was too late yeah you
got better [ __ ] too late like they
introduced like some like decent
characters they killed off like most of
the lame ones what it came on when it
came on it was it was hardcore I said
man this is pretty good it's got some
testosterone behind it then
then it went [ __ ] soy-based where
people were living who shouldn't have
lived you know I mean there were
characters that should have been long
dead yeah
just because they were cute so they kept
them on you know oh that's it that's the
thing it's like you can't get into a
thing where especially you know in a
zombie apocalypse situation where the
cute people live yeah well yeah because
it's like their fan favorites and it's
like if we're like we can't kill them
off because then no one will watch the
footage yeah yeah and then like they
just [ __ ] Salazar which is one of
their best ones when they finally
brought him back he's [ __ ] up this
just the walking dead did that - oh no I
have heard I don't know if any of you
guys are
watching it still but that I liked like
the introduction like in season 8 of
walking that I like the Internet they
finally got around to doing the
whisperers and stuff and so that was
good yeah I got kind of annoyed that
like you know Rick left but you know
Andy Lincoln I guess didn't want it like
a break from the show which he no fair
enough because he's been on there long
enough but I have heard through the
grapevine I have tried not to spoil it
because I'll probably watch the whole
season when it's um comes out on Netflix
but I have heard that this season of
Walking Dead is really really good watch
I don't know but Walking Dead hadn't had
a bad habit of [ __ ] the first three
seasons were [ __ ] kick-ass you know I
mean but then they their best characters
their [ __ ] meanest [ __ ] most
survivable characters you ended up
making them [ __ ]
you know like here's not here what was
that guy's name I can't remember the
black dude who is [ __ ] crazy here is
not here oh yeah yeah Morgan Morgan yeah
I love that [ __ ] character then they
turned him into a [ __ ] well the thing
was [ __ ] badass when he was crazy
thing they did about with him though was
that he kind of like went back and forth
in a way that to me strained credulity
yeah well I think what it was is that
they just didn't that it's even they
didn't know what to do with him know
that me when they went off to fear the
walk is just [ __ ] [ __ ] which
seemed like but like I said you know a
in a zombie apocalypse situation it's
like once there's only so much you can
do and since the show's been going on
for however many years that's been on
like nine or ten years it's like you're
gonna run out of [ __ ] to do and it's
like you're gonna get to a point where a
zombies aren't really a threat anymore
because they're just all like rotten
done [ __ ] so what made what made the
Walking Dead good is the fact that
characters went bad and they [ __ ] has
stayed bad and they got worse you know I
mean it was like a hopeless situation
Rick was [ __ ] crazy remember that he
was seeing his dead wife worse yeah and
Alvis getting into it cuz they were just
losing their [ __ ] minds and I should
have just kept on going that way you
know but they got I'll now let's bring
it back get it we're gonna well like I
said that was kind of like I mean
you're not gonna have any conflict or
drama if everyone's just a terrible
person but I feel like what they kept
doing was they kept going back and forth
too much like this person like this
season this person is gonna be evil but
then next season they'll be good and
then this one is good this season but
it's like then then next time it'll be
evil so I just feel like there's you're
thinking too much like a writer well
that's that's who works on the show you
get a play situation like that it's not
a stories of good versus evil eventually
just becomes a world of evil versus evil
with that so that's you know there
should have been no good guys at all
everyone should have been [ __ ] bad if
you want to call them bad just they just
had weak and strong didn't matter what
didn't matter if it was good or bad yeah
there was just that's the way that
series should have been but what it is
that didn't fit their philosophical
motives yeah oh my god we can't do it we
don't want should we don't want to train
people in the ways of the dark side
that's what they're for to say it he has
me well but that was more realistic well
like I said and sometimes things that
work well in reality don't work well in
fiction either but like I said I don't
I've heard that the last that the last
season was good but I haven't watched it
so I don't really know I will watch it
when they drop it all at once because
what I'm talking about is what made good
Mad Max movies good yeah where they were
all it was all gray yeah yeah I mean
like you know immortan joe you know that
he was the bad guy in [ __ ] fury road
but was he the bad guy yes I don't think
so he was just a warlord
he had yeah I had all this water and all
this stuff and he was trying to preserve
civilization and bring it back later
he couldn't share with wastelanders
because they were genetically [ __ ] up
he was trying to breed new breeding
stock and they were something from the
past and he was saying I'm gonna make
all this rise from the ashes you had to
break a few eggs you know I mean to make
an omelet the he was recruiting all the
good people that people that have had
the
that's genetic stock and and his guys
are willing to die for him the war boys
they were half-life's they weren't gonna
live very long so they were fighting to
rebuild society and if you were to just
open the floodgates like a good person
would have done they just would have
[ __ ] eaten up all that food
contaminated the water and then they'd
ended up dying anyway although I kind of
felt like watching that movie I kind of
felt like that was what
immortan joe said that he wanted to do
but I don't think that he really he was
because he was doing it remember he had
the hydroponics go and and he had the
best female breeding stock inside this
damn dome what was filter in the air so
they weren't breathing in the particles
and he was trying to have children
because evidently children were like a
rare thing when they were yeah and when
they were born they were [ __ ] up and
his sons were all [ __ ] up he had a big
[ __ ] son who was you know like a
child a childlike son that was mentally
who was intelligent or the one that was
looking through the telescope and they
had one in the middle who was just a
[ __ ] psychopath psycho yeah he never
said anything so he none of them could
inherit the throne so yeah he was just
trying to hold a base together and you
couldn't hold it together by being a
nice person in those in that situation
bad that women didn't get a choice in
the matter
ex no they did they did they were
recruited members some of them wanted to
go back well no they wanted to go back
as they didn't have like once they got
out to where they weathers no there's
nothing out there have been out there
but they didn't have a choice you know
well yeah you'd have a choice you can
either die have nothing and just live
out a bunch of mutants or you can go
back and try to give give birth to like
a royal child that was the thinking yeah
and everybody was fighting to get on
those platforms to get into the Citadel
well cuz that's where all the [ __ ] was
it's all the [ __ ] was what was the last
of the [ __ ] though was the last of the
[ __ ] you couldn't share so you're trying
to share a situation like that you'd get
me killed
alright when you when there's a when
resources are limited you have to
[ __ ]
you have to be a kingly figure to say
these people will have it but these but
it's wasted on these because we're all
dying anyway it's all temporary you're
trying to rekindle a flame of
civilization it's too complicated it's
too concretely she's moralizing things
well I mean he gets down that brutal
there's morality is not a factor yeah
because if you use morality everyone
will die and how is that moral yes
that's not moral yeah it's the whole
it's the whole Titanic thing if the
Titanic goes down and you got you're in
the lifeboat and everybody's trying to
get in the lifeboat but it's already
filled to capacity you got to fight
those people and get him out of the
lifeboat or everyone will die and that's
you know it's not moral to let everybody
die yeah so that's what and Morton Joe
was doing yeah now it makes me want to
watch fury road again yeah it was I've
seen that like tender so I had a soy boy
[ __ ] at one of those [ __ ] at the
Horicon who was up there at the panel
with me and he tried to say no he was
evil and I was like no not really and a
lot of people in the in the audience
agreed with me cuz you know he it was it
was desperate times you know you
couldn't share yes there was just a
little bit yeah you know and you didn't
want to waste it on people that didn't
have weren't gonna have a long lifespan
anyway yeah so that's what that's what
the moral was that reminded me to that
last night before we watched a very my
also watched cherry mm yeah yeah go back
yeah that was that's on free yeah and by
YouTube movies free yeah if I hadn't
seen that since I was a kid my brother
used to have a punk band that they named
no but I think I I think we get it for
free because I paid 20 bucks a month for
you to yeah is it just because we have
like the maybe I don't know but Cherie
mm was it actually it actually aged well
it it looks a lot better than then it
looked on VHS well and it's kind of like
a cross between Blade Runner and Mad Max
and Tank Girl the Bond movie funders
yeah it's like
it's not it's not like nearly as good as
the Mad Max movies no but it's more like
it reminded me of a boy and his dog
words do a lot like the the kind of
different budget similar I haven't seen
it since probably like [ __ ] it's like
a bigger budget version of boy and his
dog
yeah I really liked Melanie Griffith's
hair yeah she had that many stainless
mini-14 with a fake suppressor on it
Falcon folding stock she had that damn
60 65 Mustang good stunt work and it is
a 65 Mustang with big [ __ ] fat tires
big truck tires on it going through the
wasteland yeah I guess our show I guess
it was supposed to be Vegas or when it's
mostly Las Vegas
yeah around los tengo yeah yeah I missed
the beginning cuz I was like dealin
smother [ __ ] but yes around Las Vegas
somehow somewhere I think yeah cuz I
think some of the casinos and [ __ ] were
like under that and and actually those
the sets were actually pretty good too
that they it looks like they actually
built so it looked like you know the top
of the casinos was like sticking out
from the sand it had different tribes
some tribes were in big cities and they
were just kind of like yuppies and Blade
Runner type yeah yeah I was like I was
making a joke as I like I'm like is this
the Gilligan game they had another tribe
out there the thought they were living
in the early sixties yeah you know
[ __ ] flamingos and [ __ ] [ __ ]
Hawaiian shirts and looking what was the
deal with they all had with my insurance
and then they had like swim trunks but
then they all had like white pants
underneath the swim trunks was just part
of their that was part of their look
part of their thing they're just trying
to look dressy well they were run by a
big old jock that's true
ya know that was like my worst nightmare
I'm like oh my god yeah that's right
there was just a big old [ __ ] job I
would rather this [ __ ] gangster Mad
Max with like all the leather yeah I
think I'd be hanging out with that it's
like I'm not hanging out with this that
goal parties and stuff - yeah living in
a dome City little domed houses and yeah
it looked like a resort it did it all
like a recess Sky Ranch Sky Ranch with
the go yeah yeah it's like something out
of Fallout God it what yeah well you can
see that like the makers of fallout like
kind of
all these all those post-apocalyptic
movies and like went all in the research
and everything because that's one of the
the cool things about the [ __ ]
Fallout game series is that the [ __ ]
amount of detail that goes into that
[ __ ] it's just amazing yeah you know
what I mean I can sit there and just
like watch him playing it just like
walking around like decorating is yeah I
[Laughter]
don't know why I could just watch that
all day plus like the music is like
relaxing I guess I don't know all right
so are you done for the game done I go
should I go dude yeah I can talk these
people all day long come on you got to
make a pizza
yeah gonna make beats me he's gonna make
a pizza although we did discover while
we were out getting Damien restaurant
that fifth element cuz I thought they
closed it's up there by Sam's with the
liquor stories and we went there and I
was like oh the open sign is on so we
went and they have like all the takeout
menus in front so I think tomorrow we're
gonna like gets median food we're gonna
like order a whole [ __ ] on an Indian
food because I want them to still be
open when the apocalypse is over cuz
that's not like a really good restaurant
yeah alright so have a good rest of your
Monday and we will talk to you again
tomorrow